Hello everybody welcome to another business Q&A super excited to be back. We
didn't get a game in yesterday so I kind of miss it. It was Thanksgiving for us
here in Canada so it's it's great to be back on the attack. I'm joined by my
usual co-host Rishi Cup TV. Rishi welcome aboard.
Hi guys. Cup of love everybody.
Cup of love. I love it. I've got cup of vitamin water as usual. I haven't haven't
drunk it down yet. G-Rice also in the house wanted to do a new experiment. He's
gonna try playing support Sona in the bottom lane so we'll see how that goes.
That should be interesting. Good. You already said what was in your cup. What are you
drinking though? So I'm trying this new vanilla coffee that actually someone
gave me and I always love when I get a free bag of coffee but it's terrible. This
coffee is so bad. So I probably won't be drinking this anytime soon but other
than that I am just feeling a cup of excited for a new opportunity to hang
out with Evan and everybody and answer some questions so there you go. We won't
give that person a shout out in the comments of who bought you that terrible
coffee but but it was probably with lots of love. It absolutely was lots of love
yep and that is so appreciated. Well before getting to the questions let's
get some shout outs. We've got Soul Forge 24 53 relaxing sleep station, Jenn so
much, you guys, Rise Online, UshiCupTV. I love it. The chat is already heating up.
Let's do it. I'm ready for a question. Let's help some entrepreneurs. Yeah and
just shout out to Zano. He actually wanted to let you know he wasn't able to
be here today but he's had to tend to some family. Somebody in his family had
to go to the hospital today so we're sending thoughts and prayers to Zano
and his family today. Much love Zano, much love. Yeah okay first question coming from
Rickson and Rickson says is there any advice you can give someone that wants
to build a business or that's about to but never actually had one? Does every
business require business plan to lay out the purpose goal mission where it
wants to go projected growth in the foreseeable future? All right so you
know I would say that depending on what business you know the type of plan that
you're going to make is going to be different. Evan I know has much more
wisdom on business plans and that sort of thing but what I would just say is
the most important thing is to first understand what what value you want to
give and whether that's going to be coming through a product or a service
and making sure that before you go into all of the other plans and strategies
that you really feel confident that you're giving a very good you're that
you're confident in the value that you're providing and you're confident in
the product or service that you are are wanting to give. So I've lined up as mid
and GRI is a support and I'm gonna see if I can play some Heimer mid today it's
been a while. Nice. Blessed out the Heimer instead of the Teemo but we'll see how it
goes. So the question was what started business but has no idea how one advice
on what to do as a first step? Yeah it sounds like he feels like he doesn't
know whether he should have a very specific plan you know in starting and
so that's kind of what he wants to know is you know does he have to have a
business plan that has projected growth and all of that kind of thing. So you
know planning is super important and then also understand that as soon as you
get started the plan gets thrown out the window but it doesn't mean that the plan
is not important. It depends on the kind of person you are the people who plan
too much need to plan less and go and do and the people who do too much need to
do less and plan more. Oh we lost the game what happened? Okay I may not get
Heimer mid anymore. If you've never started a business before the best thing
to do two things one is go work for an entrepreneur go find a company ten
employees or less that's in your industry that you look up to that you
want to be like and go learn from them and learn about the industry like if you
want to be you know a caterer right okay great you love cooking you want to be a
caterer go work for a small catering company you know go work for someone is
doing some innovative new stuff that's different than the others and go you
know somebody you look up to you like and you know in a couple years I want to
be like this person but do it my way go work for them learn the ropes one
see if catering is even for you like you may start working they say you know
what I love cooking but it's I don't want to be in the catering business this
is too crazy. Better you figure that out on somebody else's dime than you
launching a catering company and then realizing that you hate this. That plus
you'll start to learn the industry you'll get experience you'll understand
what it takes I would take on as many projects as I could get as close to the
CEO founder as I could not just do the job that I was hired to do but go away
and above because yes I'm making money it'll help me you know get promoted or
whatever but really what I want is the education you know you pay to go to
university here you're getting paid to learn about your new future potential
business so I would do that immediately the other thing I would do I blend up
this team a jungle again back to Teemo guys we had we had a moment we had a
moment of potential there we're back to jungle the other thing is I would also
start on the side start your business on the side start your catering business on
the side do friends and family and weddings and you know people in your
network I would just start it with with as low risk away as possible investing a
little bit of time but but no money until I had money coming in and then
maybe as a third thing just start consuming content that that enriches you
and fills you up whether it's this channel whether it's books whether it's
other YouTube channels where there's podcasts things that get you inspired
that teach you new things that those three things get a job where you can
learn start your business on the side immediately and create a plan of
learning from other content I think we'll we'll set you up on the right path
and good luck great still not in the game right we're worse we're trying to
get a game on here we're in our picking and banning mode here so J rise got
support I have jungle but that we haven't officially started yet so we'll
see okay cool so next question is coming from a rouge and a rouge yeah and a rouge
says hey Evan hope you are fine hey a rouge I hope you're rocking it too nice
I've seen the video but I don't know how to encourage myself I am sick and tired
of my surroundings please do help me so it looks like she saw a video about
encouraging yourself she says she doesn't know how I'm sick and tired of
my surroundings please help yeah definitely easier to receive
encouragement from others than to encourage yourself but I absolutely
think there is a need to do so especially they're just gonna be times
when you're just gonna have to tell yourself you know the things that you
need to hear when it when it gets to be harder so I try to practice that I just
literally sometimes I just write out you know things that I know bring
encouragement to myself I could write it down on a card I could put it on my
mirror I could put it on my phone and so I have it handy so when you start to
feel discouraged you can pull it out quickly and read it to yourself you know
and I find that when you when you say it out loud there there tends to be a
more powerful effect and then in terms of environment you know I don't know what
your situation is I don't know if you are sick and tired of your surroundings
I'm not sure what that specifically means but I would just ask you you know
is there anything you can do to change your environment you guys see Evans wall
right now he's got all of the famous entrepreneurs and his family and parents
and Nina and all these people that for him uplift him and inspire and motivate
him to do what he does so I think that's a great idea you know you can even start
by putting things up in your walls again words of encouragement or whatever it is
that that makes you feel more motivated so there's a lot of different ways that
people approach that well our game somebody left so we're trying to start a
new one and I got mid again so I might be back to Heimer so let's see what
happens when I actually get a game on here instead of just sitting in champ
select um yeah I think the environment is super important I think most people's
environment sucks I think most people have people around them who don't help
them do great things I think people walk around pretending like they have
everything figured out but everybody is just really massively insecure and
that's why they hate on your ideas because you're trying to do something
different and you're trying to bet on yourself and you're trying to do the
thing that they probably want to do themselves and because they don't they
don't go out and do it then they have to tear you down because you having success
with it impacts their self-esteem because they're not out doing it too
they're too afraid so they have to pull you down and that sucks and so I'd be
thinking about everything from my physical environment Rishi talked about
my wall right and I you know they can't see the whole wall because the twitch
stream is a little cut but if you watch YouTube you'll see the big wall but the
first person you see is Howard Schultz here on the twitch stream and you know
that may mean nothing to you you may hate Howard Schultz or you don't know
anything about Howard Schultz and that's cool it's not that there's only one
person to put up it's figuring out what's motivating for you like when I
walk into this room I've got all these people that I look up to and respect and
learn from and that gets me jazzed right that gets me excited that gets me
motivated how can I not go out and pound on my craft when I've got these people
staring me down every day and so whatever your physical environment is
you can work to make it better even think about it you know if you're doing
work on your computer what's your desktop background you were you doing
work on your phone what's what's the phone background the environment matters
I would also look at what are the habits and routines that you need to be
successful what do you do every morning to prime yourself for success right do
you you know do you join us on the gratitude stream or in the League of
Legends stream or whatever it is for you you know I wake up and one of the first
things I'll do is put on some music and I have a belief playlist and it's public
you guys can check it out but you know again there are songs that make me get
excited a lot of them may not be relevant to you and that's fine it's
figuring out the music that gets you pumped because when you wake up at least
for me I wake up I feel like every day I'm starting from scratch and I need to
build myself up to get ready to get ready to do something awesome because if
I had an amazing day yesterday I feel like the momentum is gone the next day
or if I had a crappy day yesterday I also feel like the momentum is gone the
next day and so putting on music instantly changes your state gets me
excited gets me moving which I think is important I'll do a quick workout for 20
minutes while watching something we're going to learn from watching
entrepreneurial videos watching my channel learning something from some of
the people that are on there and then I'll have a 10-minute shower and then
I'll hop on to the gratitude live stream and rinse and repeat every day and
that's what works for me you got to build in a routine that works for you
and most importantly you know creating you know if you don't have the people in
your life that are motivated and building you up then you need to create
the resources whether it's watching the Expressos of the top tens or or
something else listening to Tony Robbins or reading a book or whatever it is
don't just kind of accidentally do it on a Thursday afternoon because you
stumbled across something build that into your day consistently so I'll be
looking at what are the things that that constantly like whatever this thing
happens to me I'm motivated and pumped up and ready to go and then design that
so that you do it daily build that into your morning routine so that you're
guaranteeing that you're gonna get that feeling almost every single day instead
of it maybe accidentally happening on a random day we are getting into a game I
am hi Mermid all right I got Heimer I have got some I've got some lag for some
reason I don't know what's going on there let me close Dropbox close Dropbox
close Drive maybe Alex is doing something hopefully he's not downloading
something 40 40 ping that's not great anyway yeah those those those two things
having having an environment a physical environment that really makes sense for
you and and having a morning routine and habits that you do consistently to to
get you motivated and excited it's a great start from there you can look at
you know the actual work that you're doing the friends that you're you hang
out with you know the other investments that you make it to yourself but I don't
want to give you a thousand things to work on and then nothing gets done so
just focus on those two your physical environment and your morning routines
and habits you change those things that make a big difference I promise I'm
gonna see if Alex is doing something on the internet it's fine okay he's not
doing anything it's just a little slow today all right that's okay what do we
have that it's not today what's all right we got it before moving out I'm
gonna close the door before doing that Rishi what what's your morning routine
look like so my morning routine is first thing I do is I do my morning pages you
know about that one which I absolutely love and I you know I'll say I used to
not I used to like journaling but I was so inconsistent with journaling and I
realized that what morning pages does is it allows you it's basically a called
like brain drain and so you can write three longhand pages of literally
everything and anything that just comes to your mind and anyway I just I found
it to be hugely helpful for me and so I always do that first thing in the
morning and then I usually will buy it by that point my coffee is percolating
in the background and so these days I then I shower and I get ready for biz
Q&A because this is now a part of my morning routine so let's see here yeah
that's kind of my morning routine right now but I I love this biz Q&A because
for me like I absolutely were you were talking earlier Evan about like what are
the things that kind of get you pumped up and excited and feeling good and for
me it really does come down to being able to connect with people and so when
I get to be on this stream chatting with you and then chatting with people in
the live chat it's just like that to me is makes me come alive so it's been a
cool addition to my morning routine I love it oh and gratitude she was now
become a part of my morning routine so there you go love it yeah all right well
we're in game my ping is still 40 something which isn't great but
manageable so we'll see ping is how how long I don't know something per second
it's per 40 it's milliseconds I don't know what it does it's basically how
fast the response is when I press a button how quickly it takes to happen
and usually I'm playing around 20 something now it's 40 so it's basically
twice as long to get something to happen which when you're in a big fight is not
great but it's all good you're still doing it all right we got
next other morning we've got other morning routines like chocolate for
breakfast oh that's yesterday and yesterday we thought you were having
turkey for breakfast all right okay we got a question from the live chat
actually a relaxing sleep station okay great and so relaxing sleep station
says a few of them so okay this is a follow-up question for his collab
because he asked a couple of weeks ago about collab collabing and how to kind
of go about that he says I'm ready to make the pitch to my potential collab
partner what I'll give a video that I've made that requires them to do nothing
but upload everything else done yeah I'm gonna read that again what I'll give one
I think that's a typo what I'll give a video that I've made that requires them
to do nothing but upload everything else done so it looks like he would give
a video to this collab person and up they would they don't have to do
anything other than upload it he continues continues to say to use my
content on his paid membership site allow them to sell my music on iTunes
maybe ask for 50-50 split for use the music video to do a guided meditation
over what should I ask okay for use the music video to what do I ask for in
terms of exposure exposure from my channel I'm sorry relaxing sleep station
I feel like I'm messing up your question here are the options that he's here are
some ideas of what he could ask for one a link in the description to my channel's
homepage to annotation the video first 15 seconds linked to my home page three
maybe he could mention the collaboration in one of his face to camera videos
before it is released the same as above for the guided meditation video so looks
like he has this the person that he wants to collab with is could expose his
music and if I'm wrong about that relaxing sleep station let me know but
anyway do you need more Evan do you need more to be able to answer this I'm a
little bit confused but so so he has music he wants to collab with somebody
who will put the music on on their channel and he's asking what he wants in
return yeah that's how I'm understanding it relaxing sleep station
can you agree or confirm if that's if we're understanding it correctly okay
all right and maybe while he's writing we could go to another question well
let's let's let's let's stay there how would you answer that I'm gonna forget
about it so okay um so I think the main thing that I would say is it sounds a
little bit like what he's asking for in return a link in the description and
annotation or a mention it sounds as if to me he feels like apprehensive about
what he should get in return and my understanding of collaborations is that
it's mutually beneficial so you want to go into the collaboration with an
understanding that you want to benefit from it as much as they would benefit
from it unless this channel that you are wanting to pitch is a much larger more
successful channel because obviously in that case they're helping you out more
than you're helping them in most cases so I wonder if if that's why he feels a
little bit like it seems to me a little bit reserved about what he feels he
asked for in return so if it's a bigger channel I would just say yeah it would
be definitely benefiting you in a collab with a larger channel because there are
audience there you're they're giving you the exposure to their audience and
absolutely I would say maybe I don't I don't think there's I think it should be
more than fair that you get a link or a mention or something because it's you
created the content it's still your content so you'd want people to be able
to find you after that I mean I just perfect example Evan I am a perfect
example of that where your channel could eat my channel for lunch in size so you
know it's like I think earlier on I think you I think my first video on your
channel was one of the videos I made for our business group and and you asked me
hey could I share this on your channel I was like absolutely because I recognize
there's such a value for me and being able to get in front of your audience
because you know at that anyway so it's just important to recognize when you're
dealing with a larger channel that there is a difference in dynamic and then if
you're working with a channel that's got the same numbers as you yeah there's a
thousand ways to skin a cat you know like there's tons of ways that if you
negotiate a deal there's so many different ways to do it it's figuring
out what's most important to you like what what's the most important thing you
want to get out of this is it money is it exposure is it is it a link is it
people talking about you is it buzz is it you know SEO because you want to link
from their website you know what what's what's the most important thing that you
want to get out of this what's a win for you and then you know you can always ask
for more but this is this is what you want to get out of it you know in any
deal you want to you want to have an idea of what you want to get out of it
so it's just understanding the dynamics of that deal you know I don't I don't
know I don't know this person it's like I don't know who who's Charlie trying to
get on to you know when we've used people's music in the past I always give
credit Oh a team is fighting can I do anything about it where did he go where
did he go where did he go what happened where did he go puppy where did he go oh
no I was all set to help in a big fight oh he went there oh my oh very sad we
lost I ran away we lost oh that was not well executed on my part all right
no we didn't lose the game just lost that fight oh good yeah so there's no
one answer like I would I would make a list of all the things that I value most
and then I would try to get all of them but recognize that what are you willing
to walk away from you know like at some point you want to get paid for the work
that you're doing you know if so example for me people people remix my stuff
people take people take my stuff all the time people take my speeches you know if
I go on a rant or whatever they'll take that and mix them up into motivational
videos or whatever right I don't I love it like I don't care I don't I don't
copyright claim them I don't like if they added a link to my my channel that
be awesome but if they don't I'm grateful for the exposure you know even
on a small channel it doesn't it doesn't matter to me it's part of my bigger goal
of what I want to do to reach you know a billion entrepreneurs you're helping me
so thank you now not everybody takes that mindset you know I've done videos
on even even look at the people that I've done videos with we did I've done a
whole bunch with Gary Vaynerchuk using his stuff remixing his stuff he's
totally open to whatever right I could take as much of the content as I want to
do whatever I want with because I mean obviously it's a positive in a positive
way for him but I'm not saying you know Gary Gary sucks but he wants the
exposure he recognizes that's way more valuable than anything else
Jim Rohn made us take down the content that we were working on with them
because they you know what they would rather sell product they don't value the
exposure they'd rather just sell product you know you know I think it's a
wrong move like is Jim Rohn the best known person in person development he
might have been but he's not anymore he's losing relevancy because he's not
on YouTube and he's not sharing the content but that's fine that's their
business practice right so I know like everybody values different things right
Gary values one thing Jim Rohn value something else other people value other
things you know I value I value different things I try to give credit to
the people that I collaborate with featuring their you know Twitter handles
links to whatever but you know just whoa I'm under attack all right I made it
through that minute through that so so everybody is different in every
negotiation it's understanding what's important to them and understanding
what's important to you and so having the conversation a lot of times the
things that you really value are things that they don't care about right like
yeah that's easy I know I don't care about that sure no problem
whoa under attack I just died very sad I got ganked man my Hymer mechanics are
off I haven't played Hymer in a while I'm struggling I'm not I'm not as fast as I as I
usually am but that's okay it's okay we're gonna I think I think we're gonna
win this anyway so I wanted to give an example and I got distracted by my death
just dying notice you know oh this is an example with trying to dance salsa you
know we we get opportunities to go and do TV gigs basically you know they want
to do a show they want to promote their their hosts kind of like talk shows
right where we get off or they're doing any some kind of TV show and they want
us to come on and either dance for them or teach their hosts how to dance or do
all this other stuff we have another one that came up last week that Alex went to
and I'm looking forward to seeing the footage from and he was asking me well
do we do we ask to get paid for this like what do what what's what's our
usual process I got the turret and I said I don't I don't need I don't need
money from the TV station like a lot of these guys don't have budget anyway
right so I don't need I don't need money from them what I'd like from them is
like one just the exposure is good enough right just being on their TV show
is a win right just getting attention is a win let's get this guys let's get
this we're fighting over over dragon they got it unbelievable holy cow
I should be juggling poppy where's your smite poppy come on
holy cow terrible oh that was terrible anyway I'm happy just for the exposure
right any time station that wants to do something even youtubers like you want
to come and do something you want us to teach you how to dance whatever I I'm
happy for the exposure it will not cost you anything and I want to do it the
actually that we asked for is a link from their website the reason why I ask
for that over something else is because traditional media companies count a lot
towards SEO mmm so if I want my website to rank locally for Toronto salsa
lessons or whatever then having links from a bunch of media sites helped me a
lot that that I would be more valuable than a link on there you know a shout out
on Twitter where they don't have a huge engaged following yeah right or a link
from their Facebook page or you know whatever so every time is a judgment
call but one I'm happy to do it even if we get no link and what I want is just
the exposure and ideally some kind of copy like can we get a copy that we could
put in our YouTube channel showing off that we were part of this show and a
link from their website so that's what I go on asking for and sometimes we get
all of it and sometimes we get none of it except for the you know the actual
exposure but I'm okay like I'm not gonna walk away from that I still want that
exposure yeah so what's your walk away point what do you need understanding that
helps you make the decision so I ideally love all three of those things you know
if I can't get it then let's go as far as we can and sometimes they care a lot
about it and sometimes they can't do anything about it like they have systems
and procedures that they have to live by and sometimes it doesn't start a big
deal at all so yeah you know we have we have shown outs and we don't usually put
a link but we have shown us anyway so why don't we just put a link back cool
so you have to know what you want ideally and then bring it up and see see
how they are with it some people are fine and some people you know they're
they're gonna push back so it's good to get the feedback good luck oh I'm glad I
came with that example we saved it hopefully that helps did was there any
more clarity on what the question was or did we help there yeah well it does turn
out that he is a small channel and reaching out to a channel that is larger
so it has the potential collab would be 200 channel that has to over 200,000
subscribers he has he has three right now and actually really hasn't started
so we'll be launching soon and that sort of thing and I for anyone who's
interested I did there is a video out there too and I think this is kind of
just relevant because this is my favorite gamer channel alloy seven and
he has a video called how to make bigger youtubers want to collaborate with you
and he talks about how he is a bigger channel the things that he has looked
for when he has smaller channels reaching out to him and he's a lot like
you Evan like he's not against working with small channels but there are some
things that he values if someone is going to pitch him so that that video
again is called how to make bigger youtubers want to collaborate with you
by alloy alloy seven and and yeah he kind of relaxing sleep station just said
uh he wants yeah he's kind of saying he wants to get as much much exposure as
possible so it looks like for him the value for him is going to be the
exposure so think everything you said evidence is going to be what uh what he
is was looking for so okay cool and also to understanding what your endgame is
helps like I value exposure way more than money because I want to be so I'm
fine with you using my content on your channel and if that helps you great you
know I don't I don't block it or content ID it I want my message to spread it's
way more valuable to me losing my voice here it's way more value to valuable for
me for that message to spread then for me to make a couple blocks off of ads
that come from your channel nobody feels that way but it just depends on what
your long-term objectives are so thank you for the question I love it the live
audience interaction yeah love it all right next question is coming from Tino
and Tino is asking greetings to you sir Carmichael I feel like you are you know
everything do you realize it I thought I was the only one who called me sir and
then I thought everybody does so you must I don't know it's kind of funny sir
Carmichael I come from nothing but I only have one request sir please be my
mentor please help and mold me into becoming an entrepreneur that the
community community can benefit at large I have ambitious dreams but no positive
mentor till I found you online you inspired me in grit in the greatest of
ways so far since I've watched your YouTube videos I stopped procrastinating
and I feel good about it I'm a recent high school graduate who is passionate
entrepreneur since I was 16 my sorry my vision is to bring innovation to Africa
Zimbabwe where I live and love I observe dreams think and dwell on breakthrough
business I find can be of benefit to the African community at large but my
only and biggest struggle is to find funding to start any of these businesses
I am currently working on a project to curb music piracy in Zimbabwe no one
takes it's a big issue but no one takes it seriously I hope you read my email so
all right I know that was kind of a lot so basically he's a 16 years old recent
graduate from Zimbabwe and he wants basically to kind of go fight music
piracy and ends up in Zimbabwe but he feels like he's being held back by the
fact that he doesn't have a mentor so there you go
did I did I are you understanding Evan sorry I want to make sure that I'm
making it clear for you yeah okay okay so I think I think it's a great first
so I just think it's great that you're reaching out 16 years old excited to
make a difference it's definitely a positive difference to be making for
sure I know there's a lot of issues around music piracy and that sort of
thing so I think that's it that's a cool thing that you're you're doing I would I
would start getting involved in music business and meeting music professionals
who are in the music business industry because I think it would give you a lot
of skills and experience because I think in the very beginning I'm not exactly
sure how how the music piracy thing would work I mean I don't have
experience in that area but I think the more you know the industry of music how
it all works and particularly you know how to protect artists from this sort of
thing the more experience and skills you can get in that area would be would be
great and I'm sure there's someone that you can get mentored from right there in
your in your area but if there isn't there's the YouTube space there's so
much you can learn right now I mean it's just incredible there's literally I I've
never not been able to find at least a step forward by doing a little bit of
research sometimes you don't have all the answers right away but you just you
you need that what next what's the next step and and then after that step it's
the next step and the next step in the next step so can you do as much research
as you can and find out people in your community that could also be a part of
that process I would start there what say you Evan what say me I say I say I
heard lack of mentorship and lack of money maybe maybe I didn't hear that
right but that's what I took from it so one I would make sure that you love this
industry because I think you I think this I think I think if you're trying to
solve piracy you're on the wrong side of history I think it's I think it's gonna
be too I think it's gonna be too easy for we're gonna fight we're gonna fight
can we win it yeah we won it very exciting I would not want to be in that
business yeah it's just it's a losing game you're fighting with you're
fighting with old old losers that's what you're fighting with the right
people just people just trying to protect what they have and not innovate
and the innovation comes in in stopping people instead of actually building a
new business model but you know there are there are ways you just got to make
sure you're fighting a massive uphill battle so you got to make sure you're
doing it because you deeply love it for some reason whatever that reason is make
sure it's there if not it's gonna be too hard and you should find something else
in terms of mentorship you know I already am right like you're watching
the videos you're making changes like that appreciate that right that's a
great start you're asking a question here right you're getting a response so
you know would it be better if you were sitting here in my office and we're
working side to side every day sure but I only do that with Alex you know you
know you could still get a lot of the benefits and appreciate the benefits
that you have I gotta go save my turret you can still get a lot of the benefits
just just by researching people online like I didn't even have this when I was
getting started I had books that's what I used I use books that motivated me
that were from famous entrepreneurs their stories or bios their histories
you know all that kind of stuff
I saved him I saved you tryndamere I used my ultimate to save you tryndamere
unbelievable okay then I I agree with Rishi about getting some experience
understanding how the industry works
you know the idea is not enough just because you have some revolutionary idea
that's gonna change piracy for forever it's not enough you got to be able to
execute on it and maybe that's you maybe you're a programmer maybe you're you
know you can hack your way into it you can you can write the algorithm that's
gonna change the world you know maybe that's it Wow nice Jay Jay just had some
insane insane play oh what was that unbelievable Wow I gotta watch that on
the replay that was crazy good well exciting exciting times here in this
game so yes the idea is not enough you have to learn to execute whether you are
the coder creating a new algorithm whether you are you know finding
partners who can help you you need to be able to build it and so get an
experience in the industry can help you learn how to get closer to being able to
build it oh these surrendered GG we won we won all right perfect timing on the
end of that question too let's see what let's see our recap here let's see it
well J rises experiment of Sona bottom seemed to work out well GG oh I went one
kill one death and five assists this totally different game than Teemo
Jerry's had four kills one death and 13 assists holy cow Jay was doing work Jay
was doing damage dealt Wow Jay was doing work that was awesome
I love it cool Wow good game well I could I also say I love it's like the
chat is just so full and vibrant of when someone asks a question now we've got
people helping out given value damasta and so forged Jen so you so much and so
much anyway the point is I got people just showing a lot of love in the chat
and and giving value and also we unfortunately had two people who ask
questions but we didn't get to today so after sourcebook and Adrian Harlot come
back tomorrow for sure and hopefully we can get to your questions tomorrow come
back at what we started like saying 915 Eastern posted and we'll answer yours
first okay I want to be able to get into those awesome well it feels good to be
victorious Rishi what is our what's our message to leave everybody on today this
cup of love to everybody in the chat for showing up and giving value and this
yeah awesome community I love it well thank you guys so much for joining we
will see you again hopefully tomorrow morning have an amazing day go crush it
I'm off to do my work Rishi's off to do hers so you go do yours continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and I'll see you soon